let there be no doubt if it moves you
can be sure it's a beast and even if it
doesn't well don't take any chances your
first playthrough of any Souls game is
always going to be that one you remember
the traps are more surprising the
enemies are more intimidating and if
you're playing on release then there
aren't any guides that you can call upon
to help you sometimes I find myself
wishing that I could wipe my memory
clean just to play these games for the
first time again and I'm sure a lot of
you guys would like that too well with
blood-borne Miyazaki says he wants to
extend that feeling you get when you
play for the first time he wants there
to be this experience that's different
every single time you attempt it and to
achieve this goal he's introducing a
dungeon in the game called the chalice
dungeon now the chalice dungeon is
procedurally generated essentially what
this means is that every time a player
enters the dungeon the dungeon creates
itself with different rooms different
traps different enemies different enemy
placement different rewards you get the
idea what you're seeing on screen now is
an example of this dungeon Miyazaki
stresses that this dungeon the one
you're seeing was made specifically for
the presentation and that the actual
dungeon will be much larger and much
more complex spanning the entire
underground of yharnam so what do we
know so far
well first the chalice dungeon is
optional and not essential to the main
game experience this is important really
important in my opinion Souls games are
tightly crafted with a lot of thought
put into their design while a
procedurally generated dungeon will be
an amazing late-game experience for
replayability procedurally generated
dungeons kind of fly in the face of the
tightly designed souls experience that
we know and love it goes against the
core of souls and I'm glad it's an
optional thing secondly the chalice
dungeon is a multi-layered underground
labyrinth there will be three layers
that present different surprises and
traps related to that layer so far we've
seen a swamp
and a crypt layer so I think that those
are the layers they're referring to
perhaps there's a third layer we haven't
seen yet activating this switch will
allow you to break the seal and access
another section here for example we see
the character finding the seal and
gaining access to the next section which
is a boss room and according to Miyazaki
even the bosses will be randomized third
the dungeon is going to be very
difficult and huge therefore a core
theme is sharing this experience with
others Miyazaki stresses that you will
be able to share your dungeon with other
players but also within small
communities and this makes me think that
your own specific dungeon will have this
code that can be shared with other
players so they can copy it which would
be awesome I have this vision of sharing
my dungeon with you guys and having you
all share your best dungeons with me
imagine that but what we don't know are
specifics which elements of the dungeon
are randomized are there hundreds of
preset rooms with preset enemies or
other preset rooms with randomized
enemies or is every single element of
the room randomized down to the rocks
and the grass we don't know the extent
to which the dungeons are procedurally
generated yet we'll just have to wait
and see but secondly we don't know how
exactly to reset the dungeon or whether
it's even possible to generate a new one
for your character some articles imply
that every character will have their own
fixed dungeons and some imply that the
dungeon will be different every single
time you enter moving on to multiplayer
I have a bit more information for you
guys a lot of coop scenes were shown in
these trailers and one was against this
ancient guard dog clad in flame and one
against a boss named priest Gascoigne
from what I've seen it seems like a
pretty good idea to have companion in
these fights because these fights are
incredibly fast paced to the point where
I worry if it's even fair
you're definitely fighting for your life
like Miyazaki said you would be back to
multiplayer though the only new thing
we've learned is that there will be
player versus player combat in some form
Miyazaki specifically says that he wants
to bring more encounters where we aid
the boss in some way similar to the old
monk fight in demon souls or the mirror
knight
in Dark Souls 2 personally I think that
we will be fighting other hunters but I
also have this feeling that we're going
to be playing against other hunters
while they're in some sort of beast form
since it was confirmed by Gascoigne in
the trailer that a hunter can turn into
a beast either when he's threatened or
when he's lost all hope who knows if he
can even turn back after turning into a
beast Miyazaki also confirmed that there
will be a mechanic similar to the human
form hollow form that we saw in the
souls series so I wouldn't be surprised
if this turned into human form or beast
form in blood-borne so what else was
shown well you can see most of it in the
trailers but let me recap for you we see
two new weapons one is a cane that can
extend into a Metallica whip while the
other is a flamethrower that takes our
gun slot we see priest Gascoigne as a
boss fight where before he helped us
fighting against the beasts the other
boss fight is this flame clad ancient
guard dog which attacks by barking flame
at you both of these boss fights are
frantic and intense just like the cleric
beast boss fight was there saying that
blood-borne doesn't have this huge focus
on difficulty but from what I've played
it definitely feels harder than the
souls games were it's also worth
mentioning that the game has been
postponed and will now be released on
the 25th of March you might think this
is a bad thing but honestly I feel like
it's a good sign too much these days we
see games coming out that are rushed
with some promise that it'll be patched
later if a games being delayed it's
because they want more time to polish it
and I'm all for that
to quote Miyamoto a delayed game is
eventually good but a rushed game is
forever bad and I want to end this video
on something that's important to me and
honestly it's one of the main reasons I
made this news video I want to bring
your attention to this throughout this
video and others you've been hearing
music made by an incredibly talented guy
named Alex Rowe alex has this uncanny
ability to take the tone and theme of an
existing piece of soundtrack and he
remixes it in a way that makes it sound
completely different but at the same
time it's also the same as what it was
before he remade a bunch of the Dark
Souls soundtrack songs and most notably
he's composed an entire album inspired
by blood-borne it's called born in blood
and you should totally go and listen to
it go and load up his music while you're
doing some work or browsing the web or
something you won't regret it
we're really lucky as a community to
have him composing for us so go and show
him some love links it down in the
description as usual thanks for watching
guys we actually have a new story video
coming next week so get hyped for that
if you enjoyed the last one on sir
alonne then you're going to enjoy this
one it's very similar to the last one in
terms of production quality so yeah feel
free to subscribe if you're looking for
more Souls news and I'll catch you next
time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]